[Music]
you know when you're going through
airport security and you've
been good you've taken off all your
jewelry put your phone in the bucket
belt off too and yet when you go through
the scanner
the alarm still goes off
when this happens we we call this a
false positive
it's when the alarm goes off for no
apparent reason
and ends up when you get in the uh
[Applause]
but then while this is all happening you
you suddenly remember you left like a
tube of toothpaste or something in your
hand luggage
and yet that manages to go through the
scanner no problem
when this happens we call the outcome a
false
negative
so in other words false positives are
negative so when the
outcomes of a a test or experiment
doesn't actually reflect what happened
in reality
and these errors can apply to all kinds
of things from
security systems to things like forensic
evidence and
even cancer screenings and so they're
really important for us to understand
because well
they can affect our personal lives
especially with this whole covered
situation as i'll explain shortly
but before i go any further first we
have to deal with
this abomination now you may have heard
these delightfully clear and not
remotely confusing terms being used in
medicine before
sensitivity is how often a test gives a
positive result for all
actual cases which means it's equal to
one minus the false negative rate
and specificity is how often a test
gives a negative result for all
non-cases so it's equal to one minus the
false positive rate
but if you're anything like me then
honestly this is about as memorable as
someone's name you just got told at a
conference
so here's a handier way of remembering
them
a mouse's existence mostly seems to be
this sort of abject
misery of stress you know constantly
freaking out at anything that moves
which to be fair is pretty justified
seeing as how small and vulnerable they
are
and so they have to make sure they catch
every real threat in order to just
survive
and so to put that into medical terms
that means they are going for 100
sensitivity to danger because they
simply can't handle any false negatives
then at the other end of the spectrum we
have this guy being a lion means that
you're kind of lord over everyone
and when you're at the top of the food
chain you don't have to worry about
getting eaten much and so
lions tend to hate being bothered about
anything
unless it's absolutely necessary and so
to put that into medical speak
it means that lions are a hundred
percent specific
because well they can't stand for any
false positives that make them
have to move
so in an ideal world we want to ensure
that whatever test we're using to
measure something
has both a low false positive and
low false negative rate so that it's
maximally accurate
but in reality that can be very hard to
do as often there's a direct trade-off
between these two things like
it's hard for a mouse to simultaneously
be alert for danger at all times
but also hang out in the sun like a lion
all day
so depending on the situation we
typically prefer to maximize
one over the other depending on which
outcome
is worse like with something like an
airport scanner
even though terrorists are fortunately
very rare
a false negative is still really really
bad because
well 911 and the same is largely true
for disease diagnosis
while obviously doctors would prefer to
have a perfectly accurate track record
it'd still rather your tests give the
odd false positive and needlessly worry
someone then
let someone who really does have cancer
slip through the net and then not get
the urgent treatment that they need
however there are some situations where
having a high
false positive rate can be just as
dangerous
and unfortunately covered 19 might be
one of them
to understand why let's imagine we have
a thousand people who want to test for
covered
and at the time of testing we predict
that say roughly two percent
of the general population has actually
had the virus
and let's say the test we're going to
use in this case an antibody test has
these error rates
which by the way are the accuracy of
some of the tests in real life
so given all this information what do
you think the likelihood is that
if you end up testing positive that you
actually
had covered in this instance before you
try and calculate it take a moment to
just feel out whatever number first pops
into your head
if you're anything like me the first
thing that came to mind was something
like
a little under 94 right i mean surely
whatever it is it's got to be
more likely that you've had the disease
then you've not had it considering
you've had a positive test result right
well bizarrely that's actually
completely not the case
despite the positive test result we are
still
most likely to have not had the virus in
this instance
and here's why so because of the 2
estimated background rate at the time of
testing
then out of those 1 000 people on
average
only 20 will have actually had the cos
and well that means 980 haven't
then because of the tests 95 sensitivity
and 5
false negative rate 19 of those 20 cases
correctly test positive and one
unfortunate soul gets a false
negative meanwhile out of the 980 who
haven't had the virus 94 of them
get the true negative result but
crucially
the other six percent get a false
positive result
and that equals 59 people
so if we then compare these two
categories of positive test results
we can see that the false ones outweigh
the true ones
by around three to one in other words
despite your positive test results you
are still
way more likely to have never had the
virus and to be abundantly clear this
relates only to this specific
hypothetical example and this
counterintuitive phenomenon
is known as the false positive paradox
it's a thing that happens when a disease
is still
rare enough that the base rate which
is the name for the fraction of the
general population who's actually had
the disease
is smaller than the false positive rate
of the test
this completely messes with our heads
because well we tend to focus on the
high accuracy of the test
and forget about this crucial first step
of taking the base rate
into account and this common error has a
name too
we call it base rate neglect and it's a
consistent problem for both scientists
and public alike
so just think about what this means for
covered testing if the background rate
of infection
is still low enough right now to be
similar to the false positive rate of
whatever test
we're using then the majority of people
who do test positive
don't actually have immunity so
while widespread testing is crucial
individually
we still need to trade very carefully
with the results we get until we
confidently know
what the true background rate of
infection currently is
it's also really important to remember
that base rate neglect and the false
positive paradox aren't just dangerous
for things like health care
they can screw up lives in other ways
too and in fact the most egregious
example of this
is the case of poor sally clark now
sally was a seemingly ordinary
law-abiding woman but who found herself
at the center of a national murder case
after two of her infant children died
when they reached a few months old
her defense argued that they had both
died of what is known as
sudden infant death syndrome a rare
but awful natural phenomenon but the
prosecutors argued that this disease was
so rare that the odds of both of these
children
independently dying of it was as slim as
1 in
73 million odds so tiny that
despite there being no other evidence
against her it was sufficient enough to
convince
judge and jury to imprison sally for
life
but in reality there were so many
outrageously basic errors in their
analysis that they
almost certainly sent an innocent woman
to jail
firstly that calculation of 8 500
squared to get to 1 in 73 million
makes the huge assumption that the two
deaths were
completely independent events but this
whole assumption is not remotely based
in reality
because it's now known that sids can run
in families due to both
environmental and genetic risk factors
and that alone would have reduced the
prosecution's odds
argument drastically but the
prosecutor's
real statistical crime was base rape
neglect
because while double sid's deaths are
extremely rare
guess what are even rarer women with
zero history of mental illness or
criminal activity
deciding to kill their babies and if
they'd actually done their numbers
properly and factored in the base rate
then the likelihood of her being guilty
would have gone from being a near
certainty
to somewhere around only 13
but despite the fact that her entire
conviction was based upon
just one piece of evidence that was in
actuality a pile of statistical horse
crap
it took three years to get sally's
conviction overturned
and even more tragically sally never
really recovered from her ordeal
and she ended up passing away a few
years later
so yeah sorry for the depressing story
but it really showcases why we need to
understand these kinds of
fallacies and concepts because covert is
forcing us to
risk assess our own health right now and
beyond that
we might end up on a jury where we
literally hold someone else's lives in
our hands
so it's really important we know how to
we learn how to evaluate evidence
properly
and more generally in this age of mass
information with all these sort of
conflicting
theories about the world going around
it's helpful to find a sort of
quantified approach to truth-seeking
finding a balance that keeps both
our false positives and false negatives
as low as possible
we don't want to be an overly skeptical
lion dismissing
any new unconventional theory we read
but at the same time
we don't want to be a gub or mouse
either believing
any and every scary new or weird
idea or theory the internet comes up
with
so on that note thank you so much for
watching uh make sure you to
subscribe to my channel because i'm
going to be making more videos on these
kind of sort of counter-intuitive
statistical topics
and of course please like and share this
video if you found it helpful because
well
you know how the internet works if you
do that then more people see it and
i'd love that so thank you see you next
time
oh and what do you think of my green
screen